In this problem we've been tasked with finding a bug. Sounds
pretty straightforward, and we've done this before, but this time we're
mixing it up a bit, and not giving you access to
the source code. We didn't really give you too much guidance
on how to do this, but, believe it or not, this
is actually a pretty common thing you're going to have to do
in the real world. Having access to the source code, or
the implementation itself, is often more rare than it is common.
Plus, sometimes even with the source code, it can be so
unfamiliar or poorly documented that it's, might as well not be having
it all. With that said, let's look at the problem. So
here we have the code to test the problem and below we
have the give and test case. Now e told you somewhere
in here lies the bug. One way to narrow it down, was
to look at each of these hypotheses and then test them
one by one. I'm going to show you a quick test case that
gets right to the bug. Here, I've inserted the
code from homework six, debugging environments and when I
run that code, I see the same bug that
we saw in homework six. This implies, and you
can further verify on your own, the problem is
right here, where we're not passing in the right
function environment when we're executing a function. So, bug
equals seven is the answer and just in case you're
curious, here's the source code for the expression evaluation, and
if we look at call, we'll see that the environment that
we call the function on is the same environment from
which its called and not from which the function was defined.